the first season was about a theme park
now it's about a very very dangerous
environment the fantasy has become
reality the gloves have come off the
guests can be hurt killed they're locked
in with the house the stakes have risen
dramatically should be a lot of fun
hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Westworld season 2 predictions
also had like a little bit of a teaser
to give us an idea for the course the
season 2 is gonna take so just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen season
1 of Westworld yet there is a new round
of the giveaway that starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be
sure to click that Bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything during the
off season so these aren't in any
particular order but some things we
actually know they're confirmed like
that little teaser that the no landscape
so number one the Noland said that order
was the theme of season 1 the west-world
people trying to keep order behind the
scenes then trying to keep the park
running trying to keep the sentient
hosts from rising up rolling them back
when they did so they said season 2 is
going to be defined by chaos so that
just means chaos in all the different
areas that they visit so you have chaos
in the parks sentient host rising up
doing as they please
chaos behind the scenes on the board so
you have people like the man in black
who might be at odds with the other
board members who want to keep the
sentient host from rising up he wants
them to continue to exist so he might
clash with them and then chaos amongst
the technicians people like Felix who
want to help the sentient host as
opposed to the other technicians that
are just trying to do their job and keep
their heads down nice try
you're not thinking big enough we're
gonna push out the old man on you
hence the urgency you're gonna need
someone to fill that position
must commend you on your impeccable
timing I want food creative control of
this place the parks the narratives the
hosts you'll be able to do with them
whatever your tiny little heart desires
as long as they are simpler more
manageable this place is complicated
enough as it is so whereas before they
wanted Westworld to seem like it was
this well-oiled machine everybody in
every different place is going to be a
complete mess it's going to make for
great drama next big one samurai world
or Shogun world depending on how you
want to think about it whatever that s
means when Felix said it's complicated
that just means that they didn't want to
explain the producers didn't want to
explain before they'd completely figured
out the concept so it just means that
another park is going to be the setting
for season two it won't be set inside
Westworld will explore the idea of
multiple parks Shogun world is just one
of those there could be many parks
beyond that but here's the thing that
really seals the deal HBO had a website
for Westworld during season one called
explore west world we just had
additional content just for poking
around mythology on the show and
recently they just registered the
domains explore samurai world and
explore Shogun world.com so that just
confirms that we're going to be going to
those places but again that doesn't mean
that that's the only place that we'll
see it just means that it'll be one of
the biggest places so they did say that
each season they just wanted to build a
bunch of awesome sets shoot an awesome
story then burn it all to the ground and
go somewhere else
meaning that in season three will go to
another park so we'll just keep going to
different parks each new season which
just sounds awesome
so next big thing mave found out about
her daughter was in park one liked this
location here so what's probably going
to happen is is that her daughter will
wind up in a different park outside of
West world like they reassigned her to
another narrative so hopefully mave in
the other sentient host will go to this
other Park for reasons of their own like
Mei will be looking for her daughter the
other hosts might flee trying to hide
from the board members there's a whole
bunch of questions about what's going to
happen to the sentient host that
involved in the massacre the big red
wedding they had at the end of the
season maybe they'll be assigned to this
other Park with a new narrative but next
big thing speaking of red wedding Ford
is probably going to actually be dead
even though his presence will continue
to be felt like an obi-wan or a Yoda
force ghost so he won't physically be a
big part of the plot of season two but
the specter of what he said in motion
will still be very present so people
will continue to talk about him talk
about the old man especially bernard
next big prediction who will sort of
take over the role that ford had in
programming all the hosts because it's
still a huge endeavor there's still a
whole bunch of other parks that are
operating somebody has to keep that
running so nobody in a position of
authority that could challenge him knows
that Bernard is a host so he'll probably
be promoted and try to balance the
sentient hosts try to help them out
while at the same time keeping the board
at bay and keeping all the parks running
so next big one a new main villain will
rise from the dello sport maybe one of
the new members that selected to fill
the seat of one of the Dead members
because they had all the board members
there maybe not every single one but
most of them were killed in that red
wedding incident meaning that giant
corporation has a bunch of empty board
seats to fill so maybe Charles dance is
available or someone like him can fill
one of those seats and become the
villain of the season so that the man in
black who continues to be somewhat of
like a gray area not really good not
really evil but still a terrible person
doesn't have to be the main villain
himself so again the thing about the man
in black is that he got what he wanted
he wants the sentient host to continue
to exist so he's going to have to do
something to protect them he's the
chairman of the board he controls the
majority of the corporation but that
doesn't mean that he's completely
invincible so even though he is a
terrible human being
there's still people on the board that
could try to oust him who are only
interested in money whereas he wants to
experience something that's truly real
so he loves what happened at the end of
the season and he wants to see that
continue another big one they'll confirm
the location of Westworld which is
probably on an island just because
Maeve's protocol
was to invade mainland that she chose to
ignore that to go back and find her
daughter so mainland implies that West
world is on an island somewhere near
another nation so that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's near the
United States or it's near China but it
could just be localized to wherever that
genre is so like West world is largely
an American thing so that could exist
near America Shogun world could be
somewhere else or it could be like a
series of islands near to each other so
this could be like somewhere in the Pan
Pacific area but keep in mind that West
world is hundreds of square miles the
other parks are probably about the same
size so they'd have to be very big
island so there aren't that many places
where you could put these parks but
speaking of dead people people coming
back the biggest returning characters
are probably going to be the man in
black just because ed Harris confirmed
that he was coming back to Loras Teddy
mave
Felix Bernard the Hemsworth brother
who's missing in action he'll probably
come back at some point and maybe some
armistice - at least for a little while
you think that they would try to
decommission the hoes that were super
murderous but because of the way Ford
turned off the security protocols I
think there's a way they could explain
armistice getting out of that situation
even though she doesn't have an arm
right now but the last big one is the
premiere date so everybody has probably
heard that because they're taking so
long to develop the season work on the
scripts they're not going to start
shooting till next summer meaning that
it won't premiere till sometime in 2018
that could be at the beginning of 2018
that could be sometime during the summer
or it could be during this time
depending on how long they hold it so as
much of a bummer is that is they're just
trying to avoid a true detective season
2 situation whereby you have this really
awesome season of TV followed up by
ability crappy season just because they
rush it and they have terrible scripts
they don't have enough time to work on
the stories to make them really good so
that's the main reason why they're
taking their time and making season 2
meaning that season 2 is going to be
amazing I think it's going to be even
better than season 1 they actually had
to stop production in the middle of
season 1 to take extra time to finish
the last couple of scripts they changed
a whole bunch of story points the
original ending they had in mind when
they shot the pilot was different from
the ending that they chose to go with at
the end of the season so they
like a much better idea midway through
so they had to halt production to fix
that so I think they're trying to
prevent that from happening during
season two so they get all their ducks
in a row and they can shoot it it'll be
amazing but it will be a while before it
gets here but we'll still do bonus
videos we have Game of Thrones coming
before then so they'll be giveaways
going on there'll be all kinds of stuff
so let me know in the comments what are
all your predictions about Westworld
season 2 and what kind of bonus videos
do you want me to do while we wait for
it to get here there's so much time that
there will be a lot of bonus videos I'll
probably do a video about the Ford is a
host or was a host in the finale theory
I don't necessarily think that it's true
but it's an interesting theory to talk
about so I'll probably do a video for
that is there any other theories that
you guys want to suggest just write them
in the comments but I'll say
congratulations to this week's Westworld
giveaway winner
drogon you win a $20 Amazon gift card be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details so I've already started
a new round I'll announce the winner the
next time I post a Westworld bonus video
next week what's going to happen next is
I'll post a trailer video for the rest
of the season on Walking Dead they've
already released the trailer for the
next episode so that should post pretty
soon there'll be some flash bonus video
and I'll be doing another Rick and Morty
video really soon - while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
all my Westworld videos and you can
click here for my Walking Dead finale
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]